bernie sanders the godfather of a lot of
these ideas is now facing a headwind
from the party that he is running to
represent here's longtime Democratic
congressman Gregory Meeks if he wants to
be a Democrat he said register in the
Democratic Party and then you can talk
about running and to be my
representative
I want a Democrat to be my
representative as president of the
United States
joining me now Michael Knowles host of
the Michael Knowles show on The Daily
wire and Austan Goolsbee economics
professor at University of Chicago's
Booth School of Business and former
chief economist under President Obama
gentlemen welcome great to have both of
you with me tonight so Michael let me
start with you you say that despite the
fact that Bernie Sanders had a pretty
impressive initial haul of money you
think that he's actually going nowhere
in this race how come I think the money
bomb means nothing people forget that
Ron Paul raised precisely the same
amount of money in precisely the same
amount of time twelve years ago Ron Paul
will never get his party's nomination
and nor will Bernie Sanders though
actually for opposite reasons I think
the argument that the congressman just
made that Bernie Sanders is not a
Democrat and therefore he shouldn't run
as a Democrat is ridiculous
who cares how he is registered Bernie
Sanders has redefined the Democrat Party
according to his radical ideological
lines all of these Democrat candidates
now are spouting at this sort of policy
proposals that Bernie Sanders in his
2016 campaign embraced and so the
question is because of Bernie's success
why would anybody vote for him now an
old white man when they have so many
more attractive candidates for an
identity obsessed already radicalized
well Democrat party well see I mean that
may be one of the reason that some folks
are pushing out videos like this of him
back in 1985 take a quick look at this
time we want to hear from Austin you
know 20 sometimes American journalists
talk about how bad
because people are lining up the food
that's a good thing
in other countries people don't line up
for food the rich get the food and the
poor scoff to death so it's good that we
have bread limes Austin what do you make
of this whole Bernie say I mean how do
you think he's gonna fare in all of this
you had to think a stronger start than
most people thought he was going to yes
and no you know it's a last time in 2016
he was the obvious receptacle of the
anti-hillary segment of the party and so
it would you know it felt like it went
forever and he was kind of the hot fresh
pizza and now the piece had been sitting
there for four years and I and I do
think Michael's right look you got
candidates from New York yeah candidates
from California there's a bunch of
different parts of the Democratic Party
let's say that each person is
representing here's an old white guy
from Vermont in a lot of quarters but
you know when you take a look at the
chances though you know of who can
whether or not President Trump can be
beat Michael let me get your thoughts on
this put up this Fox News poll excellent
19% good 36% and president Trump's
favorability rating is down around 43%
right now so you've got a pile on from a
number of people including Donna
shillelagh and then you've got the AOC
spokesperson corbin trent who says that
they refused to endorse bernie for 2020
we're excited to see many progressives
in the race we're not thinking at all
about the next election you know it
raises a lot of questions about who will
who will be ordained and just how far
left that person is likely to be in the
end this is the trouble of the Bernie
Sanders ization of the Democrat Party is
I think a generic Democrat absolutely
could be President Trump in 2020 the
trouble is there's no such thing as a
generic Democrat and when you have all
of these individual candidate so with
all of their individual weaknesses Joe
Joe Biden he's not yet in the race it
certainly seems that he's going to run
but if we're talking about stale pizza
as Austan used the phrase I think
hot pizza Austin thank you we're gonna
be talking about Bernie Sanders I think
for some time to come as we watch all
this thanks guys good to see you tonight
Thanks